a powerful tornado touched down in North
Texas overnight causing widespread
destruction it's terrifying the tornado
ravaged neighborhoods with winds
exceeding 110 miles an hour several
homes and businesses were destroyed many
cars were tossed around like toys
damaging winds uprooted trees and
knocked out power to tens of thousands
Omar Villafranca is in Dallas Omar the
damage looks pretty significant where
you are it is and this storm was
fast-moving and very powerful let me get
out of the way so you can see a little
bit of this damage this home right here
doesn't have a roof anymore in parts of
it or spread out all over this
neighborhood in fact when we were
walking to this area we saw just about
every home on this block had some
significant damage now people will start
cleaning up obviously when the Sun
starts coming up and city officials are
telling us after seeing all of this
damage they are surprised that no one
here in Dallas was killed lightning
illuminated the tornado in the night sky
as it tore its way across Dallas Palmer
al-assad was on his balcony as the
twister ripped through the suburb of
Richardson he told us he was hit as his
roof came flying off Oh guys let's go
that's it just check out the power
everywhere
the storm knocked out power across
Dallas County at one point affecting
more than 100,000 people it started
shaking it for that kind of color quick
they started moving the house around and
in the tornadoes wake a trail of
destruction this Home Depot is now
unrecognizable you can see water
spouting for broken pipes
in this neighborhood police escorted
elderly residents through the rubble of
their brick apartment building and the
tornado stripped houses like this one
down to their foundations yeah so it's
bad I've never been through this before
this woman says she was five minutes
away from sending her daughter to sleep
when the tornado hit blowing out windows
and the ceiling to her room
it feels really scary because if I was
up here again I'll get hurt
very scary indeed and let's get right to
Omar cos Omar today you're covering this
story but last night you were in it you
live in Dallas and I saw your post on
Twitter about taking shelter with your
family how's everyone doing this morning
everyone in our area is fine like
thousands of other families we heard
that tornado sirens they were going off
and you're trained to basically grab a
pillow or some sort of mattress or have
a blanket you go to the center closet
you kind of pile it on you so my wife
the hound and the three-year-old
daughter were all safe this neighborhood
though was hit pretty hard and we are
actually not far away from President
George W Bush and his wife Laura they
live around here but a spokesman tells
CBS News they are fine they're more
concerned with their neighbors and hope
everyone is doing better Tony we're glad
everyone's okay take shelter and then
call CBS News for your assignment that's
wife the hound and the daughter that
homework thank you very much